du sport justement à présent avec une
bonne nouvelle pour les amateurs
d'escaladé la salle verticale arte va
devenir deux fois plus grande les
propriétaires ont racheté un local dans
la zone d'activités du pas du lac c'est
à montigny le bretonneux les travaux
vont se terminer dans quelques jours les
grimpeurs vont pouvoir s'aventurer sur
des murs de sept salles dès le 16 avril
le reportage de michael et demi d'euros
la salle d'escaladé verticale entre va
s'agrandir le complexe ouvert depuis
décembre 2013 à montigny le bretonneux
dans la zone d'activités du pas du lac
qui va désormais disposer de 600 mètres
carrés supplémentaires
la surface pour grimper va être
multiplié par deux avec cette extension
un choix mûrement réfléchi par la
direction du centre on dit qu'on a
choisi d'agrandir déjà pour laisser plus
de place et que plus de gens puissent
venir essayer nos structures mais aussi
pour une augmentation du chiffre et un
développement tout simplement
deuxième chose c'est que l'opportunité
qu'on a eue de pouvoir ouvrir à côté
acheté le local d'à côté on a saisi
l'occasion pour développer ces nouveaux
murs d'escaladé verticale art à
travailler avec les membres de l'équipe
de france les grimpeurs de la salle ont
également donné leur avis on avait une
boîte à idées sur tout ce qui manquait
aux gens qui les grappes et tout ce qui
leur manque et tout ce qu'il leur
fallait on a eu tout un tas de réponse
tout un tas de papiers et là dessus on a
ça nous a permis de dessiner d'autres
blocs dessiner d'autres murs d'escaladé
avec cet agrandissement verticale art
devient l'une des plus grandes salles de
bloc en ile de france
une nouvelle qui ravit les aficionados
du centre pour nous grimpeur ou enfin le
rappeur c'est un grand mot mais ça va
être jugé là ça fait deux ans qu'on voit
toujours les mêmes murs ici ça va être
nouveaux
donc ya pas de mot quoi déjà la salle en
elle-même avant l'agrandissement cette
offre là le fait que ce agrandissement
ça va forcément ouvrir d'autres horizons
d'autres modules d'autres et des verts
les surplombs d'autres surfaces quoi est
ce qui fait que ça va encore à errer en
plus la salle l'extension sera
officiellement ouverte au public à
partir du week-end du 16 avril chaque
jour plus de 350 grimpeur défie la
gravité sur les parois de la structure
le tarif pour une journée d'escaladé de
13 euros